♪♪
♪ Come back, come in ♪
♪ Come and electrify me ♪
♪ I know you got
something I want ♪
♪ Shake my bones
to the floor ♪
♪ Let it all go... ♪
(announcer)
Furmanski beer.
(men laughing)
Hey.
Uh, what was-- what
was that all about?
Uh, what do you mean?
I'm sorry, were you
flirting with that beer?
Uh, I don't know,
kind of?
(men laughing)
(chuckles)
Okay.
Why would you
do that?
I was thirsty,
so I guess I was
checking out the beer.
Yeah, but you--
you seem...
excuse me,
I apologize.
You seemed, like,
turned on by it.
Oh!
Oh, you thought I was
looking at you.
Oh!
Oh, no!
(men laughing)
Oh, you're not
a beer!
No.
She didn't get it.
Yeah, I mean,
it was sweating,
in like, that way, right?
It seemed like it
was into me, so...
Well, I was into you.
Well, I can't open your
head with a lighter.
(men laughing)
So, you, like, actually wanna
have sex with your beer?
Yeah, I hadn't thought it
all the way through, but...
Yeah, still sorta
thinking it through.
(scoffs)
That'd be amazing!
Yeah, I mean, I wish there
was a beer I could fuck.
(announcer)
Dick Hole beer.
Finally, a beer
you can fuck.